separate the game clock and shot clock
this is the moment
that chris paul says he was built for he
embraces this moment going against his
former team
houston got its hands on it
dort for three blocked by hardin dort
got it back
tried to throw it off harden and missed
him
[Music]
it's rockets basketball with point five
to go
james harden don't ever talk about his
defense again what a play
and chris paul is trying to sell to the
referees that he called a timeout but
this is an outstanding job
by james harden that's a winning play
that's a winning play by james harden
not on the offensive end
but on the defensive end and then the
awareness to not allow lou dort to throw
the ball off
boyd on the floor is out of bounds
houston ball donovan designed this
playful
and they still have a timeout remaining
if they can't get it in bounds
chris paul and billy donovan has a
tandem always on the same page
always in sync giljas alexander will
inbound
and i don't like the way that pj tuck is
defending stephen adams he's got to be
connected to him they're in a zone right
now
houston rockets pretty much zoning the
areas
[Applause]
clark fox starts on the touch gilges
alexander
is going to have to burn another timeout
billy donovan all the way out at half
court
to make it happen and they're saying
that they they called
they called the foul prior to so that's
what the oklahoma city thunder is
complaining about right now
prior to the timeout
scott foster and pat freyr discussing
this
chris paul wants a review
chris paul arguing vehemently with scott
foster
for the foul first
and scott foster insisted
that the timeout will stand
[Music]
[Applause]
boy
[Applause]
dennis schroeder saw and chris paul saw
that prayer
seemed to signal foul first
he's got that right hand up prior to
giving the timeout
signal in foul
well it's going to be thunder basketball
with no timeouts remaining and
1.1 to play
a tremendous amount of conversation and
discussion
steve let's come in and steve javi let's
talk about this a little bit
it looks like scott fosse is just sick
of the foul
prior to the timeout called on james
harden
[Music]
so now we have it's an away from the
plate val anyone can shoot this
one shot and it'll be side out from the
original spot
there you go so with the ball not yet
inbounded
they say that the foul will take
precedent
so because of that situation
it'll be one free throw and possession
again afterwards personal
one shot in the ball for oklahoma city
anybody can shoot it
they still need a score even if galinari
makes the bucket here
the only difference being if he makes it
that score would count for
a win instead of a top shooting one shot
that foul was against james harden
and galinari misses it
but not a deal breaker they can still
tie it you know historically how much
grabbing and holding there is in this
situation
but again if i'm alexander
i'm looking at steven adams and the way
he's being defended
by pj tuck and billy donovan calls a
timeout and wants to talk about it
and there was no foul called on this one
we're going to the benches
with 1.1 to go that's his final timeout
neither team with a timeout remaining
neither team with a foul to give
[Applause]
don't forget right after the game it'll
be sportscenter with scott van pelt
tim legler breaking down the thunder
rockets game right here and the player
of the game
plus the controversial calls that
decided the bucks heat game mark that
you alluded to a moment ago and what
leonard fournette might do next
with his next move and what he might
bring
to brady in the bucks
but the most important 1.1 seconds of
the season
for both these teams
[Applause]
i tell you what both games tonight has
not been the finest moment
for whistleblowers
taking a lot of courage to make the
calls that they've made
and speaking of courage we'll see who
has it who gets it who makes it and
potentially
takes it for okc
bilges alexander to inbound again
schroeder adams galinari and chris paul
on the floor as well
and stephen adams just dived to the rim
he's wide open
guarded by pj tucker
and they get it blown up the houston
rockets
blow it up deflected away they tried to
get it to adams
and ball game over
the houston rockets advance to take on
the los angeles lakers
[Applause]
mike d'antoni said at some point they're
gonna have to plant their feet
and win it with some defense
it took them all of 47 minutes
and 58 plus seconds to do it and they
got the big stop at the end mark jackson
and he's right they did it on a
defensive end and it was
james hodd takes so much heat but
after that this is the play defensively
they made life tough if i'm stephen
adams i'm diving to the cup there's
there's no way he can hurt the rockets
in this situation but james harden
tough night offensively but made the
biggest play and deserves an awful lot
of credit
with the blocked shot of dortch's
three-point attempt
that's the play the play you're talking
about the play of the night maybe
for the rockets right there the block
and the hustle by
james harden and then getting out of the
way even though dort had stepped out of
bounds previously
[Applause]
james harden did not have a great
offensive night
but people remember the last thing that
you do